sinon quand je participe et de look ans
c'est bien d'avoir organisé ça comme une
répétition générale pour l'une des
quatre classes de l'iut de
mantes-en-yvelines en vue du concours
d'éloquence du lundi 4 avril prochain
chaque participant a pu choisir et
écrire son discours parmi une liste de
sujets proposés j'ai vu un peu tous les
sujets y avait rien qui m'intéressait
j'ai vu que trond sollied éthylomètre
branché ça m'a paru drôle et sympa à
faire ch des prix et c'est ce qui
ad'ailleurs mon discours cela va de
l'humour à des thèmes plus mélancolique
long terme portera sur l'essence et la
vie ça fait passer un message peut être
d'espoir à certaines personnes et des
messages aussi d'encouragement voire
même dénonciateurs moi je parle de la
maladie de mon endométriose le moyen
d'une mine de gonesse mais que personne
parle de toi il ya les hommes tuent des
guides et je le fais parce que c'est un
concours qui est proposé par
l'établissement et que j'ai été
sélectionné par un professeur de
techniques d'expression et de
communication ça apprend l'éloquence la
rhétorique le fait de pouvoir parler en
public pour l'organisatrice et
professeur corinne gaumont l'objectif de
l'événement est avant tout d'apprendre
certaines bases de la parole aux
quelques 200 étudiants participants
savoir parler savoir choisir les mots
justes les bons mots ce qui marque ce
qui émeuvent ce qui motive en fait pour
mes étudiants c'est avoir une longueur
d'avancé et donc il est important pour
moi de les entraîner de d'organiser ce
type d'événement au sein de l'iut de
mantes en yvelines outre l'expérience
apportée par l'exercice des récompenses
pour les prix mais un ipad un chèque de
200 euros et des places pour le zoo de
thoiry attribué par la directrice et
marraine de cette édition collombat de
la panoz